[Music]
welcome to your biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we're talking about
getting older
but it's not going to be boring
don't worry
we're going to talk about the process of
growing older
what we are enjoying about that
and what we're finding uh to be not so
enjoyable and it's not just going to be
talking about like
joints that are going bad and stuff like
that i mean there might be really things
that's all i got there may be a tad of
that
uh but i think it's just as we are
i don't know requesting middle age well
i mean you're just now getting settled
into 44
as of the release of this episode i
don't know what middle age is anymore
because i mean the the life expectancy
change has changed it's actually gone
down a little bit
okay
yeah i mean i feel like this is the
middle age
we're in our middle ages so things that
are changing emotionally things that
we're learning about ourselves etc etc
but
i thought a good thing we could we could
start with is uh the fact that we
recently went to a concert together with
our wives yeah we did um we went to
uh see lord huron in the hollywood
forever cemetery like you can go out the
lord huron i'm a huge fan uh
and then we saw him in a cemetery which
which
the vibe kind of fits a cemetery vibe
it's like the vibe of their music a
little bit yeah i mean i wouldn't say
it's creepy but it there's some haunting
there's a haunting
aspect to it for sure like a western
haunted
type thing yeah and we are in the right
lane and that the reverb only makes it
more haunting but i'd never been to the
hollywood forever cemetery well i had
seen a movie there because they will
show movies there in the same spot that
they do the concert which is
that big lawn and there's a giant i
think it's actually maybe a mausoleum
yeah that were and so they will
project a movie dead people drawers they
will project a movie onto the dead
people drawer building
but then lord huron just stood right in
front of it on a stage
with no it's the first time i've been to
a concert where i was that far away and
there was no screen it's not it's just
about the sounds man and there's no um
it's a cemetery that has not been made
into a place to play music so the only
light
is coming from the stage
did you notice that there's no it's no
no so like walking out of there it was
like i mean when we were packing up you
turn on your uh iphone like that's right
yeah just to find your stuff and then
we're you know we got there kind of late
we were at the back of the main lawn
area and then there's like a walking
path and on the other side of that
there's a bunch of graves and when we
turned to leave i was like i realized
that that had been filled in and there
were people just lounging on graves yeah
right
check it out i think that i don't know
if you're supposed to do that i know
you're not i mean some people believe
you shouldn't walk
also great but i would have thought this
loudly it would have been there would
have been a sign that says don't lounge
on the graves
but maybe they just thought that people
would know that kind of yeah it seems
like something you kind of know but i
mean when the place is full and you're
there you got it where else you're gonna
go you gotta prop up somewhere but when
we parked
i got to i got the special ticket to
park
inside
which i didn't know that meant just like
as parking along with the uh gravestones
as if i was going to a graveside service
you they're they're directing us all the
way through we got we got to kind of see
a lot of the the graveyard there's some
there's some famous people
uh buried there the most recent of which
that i know of chris cornell i was just
reading about i wish he would have found
his gravestone
but the thing that is uh also
significant about it that we learned
is that
the hollywood forever cemetery is also a
place where people uh who don't have the
means to maybe be buried to have a
gravestone at all can be buried i don't
know exactly how that process works
but i just know that there yeah there
are some famous people and it's been
around for a long time but there's also
some people
uh who don't have the means for that
kind of burial who get these really
awesome
grave plots and the thing that we
noticed as we parked the car and we took
the scenic route walking through these
gravestones in order to get to the
the theater location well the the the
concert
the lawn
uh pretty much all of i'll say at least
90 percent of the gravestones
had
an etching
of the person it like um like a like
sometimes more than an edging
photorealistic
etching sometimes you're saying a photo
like a printed photo almost of the dead
person sometimes in color
really impressive
a little
a little creepy i mean i
i kind of thought as i was walking by
some of them you know when you're
walking by a painting it's like is is
she watching me
but i think that's just the principle of
if the two dimensions if the subject is
looking at
the camera lens or
the simulated camera lens of
of a artistic painting they are
technically following you yeah wherever
you stand they're going to be looking at
you and that doesn't mean they're a
ghost that just means it's a painting
just how physics works or
a photo but in a normal cemetery maybe
like you know if you're going down
highway 55 uh on the way to andrew from
fuquay varina i'm just gonna use that as
a normal cemetery yeah there might be a
couple of people who've like paid a
little extra it's like oh he got his
face got his face on there but like you
said almost everyone at least in the
section that we were walking had their
photo and then that started a
conversation
i think that christy or jesse
somebody pointed it out they were like
it's interesting that most of these
people have chosen to have
a photo of them in their old age
you know presumably the last good
portrait that they had taken of them
before they died and there's a few
people and i would say a much smaller
percentage had like their peak physical
prime photo
oh when i was 25 years old when i was 35
years old and now i died when i'm 90 but
you see my 35 year old self up there and
that started the conversation about what
photo
we would have
on our great first of all i have made
the decision
i'm now going to get a photo of my my
gravestone
i mean it i didn't know i didn't know
how awesome of an opportunity this was
you now you said because you're planning
on getting cremated which i am also that
there is no gravestone yeah is that true
is it just an urn and that's it first of
all
i think i'm leaning towards being
cremated but i think that's bad for the
environment
and
from way back in the day when we did the
burying me naturally commercial that's
the name of the company that produces
like biodegradable
cardboard boxes that you're buried in
and then you the worms
come in and the maggots come in and they
make you one with the earth and you also
in the process you do not get embalmed
yeah so it's just it's a quick burial
and then you better hope you die like
close to home and we can plan your
funeral really fast and i think they
just kind of assume you're gonna die am
i right and remembering that like after
x number of years of
decomposition they can then bury
somebody else in the same spot
i think that's true after a while
i mean it's definitely true in general
it had to be buried longer than i was
just a quick cl plug if you want to
watch me get buried alive you can find
that old episode of commercial kings i
know it's available on itunes uh amazon
and amazon
uh streaming as well depending on what
country you're in
uh yeah we got that that was the pilot
episode i got buried alive and then we
also uh
made a commercial for a guy who picked
up people's trash yeah pretty awesome
heavy hill so i i don't think
i i don't like the idea of a gravestone
i mean of all the people that have been
buried like i said that day the last
time
the only time i'd visit a gravestone
is
for the gravesite service as much as i
love my relatives that have passed on
and maybe it's a function i don't think
it's a function of living in california
i think even if i was local
i don't know i just don't
something about i guess my beliefs i
just don't think i need to go there in
order to reconnect with somebody
or
pay homage i i haven't found myself
being motivated to do that
i don't know maybe it'll be different
when my mom passes away maybe i'll be
motivated to go there and like commune
with her i really but i
so it but at this point in my life
i guess because i i don't have any
connection or like ongoing experiences
at like talking to a person at the
gravestone like they do in the movies i
actually just thought that's something
they do in movies well go to a grave go
to a cemetery and see how many people
are showing up because
there's quite a few i i don't know i i
haven't done it because
um
anyone that i was close to in terms of
like my grandparents
they're all buried in georgia
so
and it's not i don't i never lived now i
feel like if i feel like if i lived in
the town
with
the gravesite of someone that i loved i
would go to it
you're totally right that you don't have
to go to i'm guessing all this though
because it's so ceremonial
it's it's the most tangible expression
of their lives
or their presence that you can achieve
it's like the body that they inhabited
whatever your belief system is not the
body that they were
it's
as close as i can get to it and if you
just have the urn in your
like even if you just keep it in your
house on your mantelpiece
it's going to be harder to make an
occasion of
like communing and reverence maybe on
the the dead relative's birthday you'll
take the urn down
and you'll like look at it and say
something but you're still in your house
and you're like okay now i'm gonna put
it back and i'm gonna do the rest of my
life but when you have to get in a
vehicle drive to a grave walk
yard drive to the gravestone and sit
there and have one of those cinematic
moments i it actually seems very much up
my alley to like
err on the side of over dramatizing
things yeah and by the way i think this
is a middle-aged thing for me to like
you know as i was talking about lilly
leaving for college and how i tended to
be i was pretty dramatic about that you
know i
now i'm rethinking if i want to if i
want a gravestone as we're as we're
talking about it right here what about a
drawer you thought about that i think
the drawers are really expensive yeah
and also all you get is a drawer with
your name on it but then you're like
right on the other side of that drawer
it's like i could yank this thing out
and i could
i could i could see what's left but with
a gravestone you can go
you can go up
you know i mean there was somebody out
there that had a literal go up
the gravestone can be really tall
oh and so there's a monument there's
really no limit there probably is like
some sort of ordinance but we saw one
guy who had
like a roman column
that was yes that was like partially
carved out of the stone and it was like
at least 11 feet tall it was sculpted in
such a way to look like a ruin yeah it
was that was cool it was actual
ruins let's see this is where the the
enneagram three in me comes comes out
because
i'm actually thinking about how
impressive my gravestone could be
like current meme
is thinking about the potential of like
winning the cemetery competition people
i know that it makes people who don't
know you you want them to come to your
gravestone just look at this stone just
i'm thinking about the experience that
somebody can have
because
it's this is a this is a very mclaughlin
thing that if my dad and my brother and
my mom and i and really just my brother
and my dad and i because my mom doesn't
really partake in this particular thing
where to visit a cemetery what would the
conversation devolve into very quickly
who has the best gravestone
right and my dad would be like well that
guy's got a column
he he wins yeah you know it's like we
would we would just that's what the
conversation would morph into is like
whoa this guy paid a lot of money to
like he's got a full color
thing and that's kind of what we did we
were doing it for kind of entertainment
purposes and that's why we would be
doing it but then once you start talking
about that you're like well what am
what am i going to do because i am on
team cremation right now
and i do understand the environmental
impact not
from my individual
cremation but the
the collective cremation right but can i
do some sort of like carbon recapture or
something of myself
what if they could recarbon recapture me
and then they could also
take that and do something with it i
don't know if there's there's got to be
other ways
like a low
like a high time
high desiccation rate kind of a thing
where it's you're not burning you
they're just drying you out and then
they're just like like a porter
uh like a jerky like i'm yeah like turn
you into jerky and then turn you into
like a mortal and pesto
jerky i said mortal and pestle water
immortal and pestle okay so we're going
to do we're going to be freeze-dried and
then crumbled into yeah i want to be i
want to be crumbling if you freeze dried
and crumbled you can still make out some
stuff oh there's some hair on that piece
you know what i'm saying that would be
uh this might yeah this could be a
nipple that could be an interesting
thing for your kids to have to sort
through
versus just this nondescript ashes that
could be a cow it's like oh there's
dad's nipple freeze-dried nipple let's
throw that into the cave river because
that's another thing i am interested in
cremation because i want to be scattered
smothered and covered
um
but so you i don't even know why so
you're going to buy a really fancy
headstone and you're no part of your
remains are going to be there no no no
no no i think if part of me will be
maybe maybe the gonads
because if i'm gonna if i'm going to
here
here lies rhett mclaughlin's gonads
freeze-dried gonads maybe they'll be in
a jar
there's probably lots of rules about
this and we're probably violating them
in theory here yeah all i know is that i
didn't like the idea of a picture
because it's very it's very committal if
you're a famous person then the moment i
guess if you die
later in life
well after the peak of your fame i would
think that you would want the
what most people
know you at like that peak fame picture
what picture do you want in the paper
what picture do you want in the obituary
what picture do you want
um i mean i don't know if we're still
relevant maybe there'll be an article i
just don't want the conversation
i just don't know that we're famous
enough
maybe we are you'd get a i i think if
one of us died we might we might trend
on twitter
probably for the first time ever but i
think that that might be what it takes
yeah but i'm i'm gonna go for it you
want to experiment i'm really no i'm
because i'm thinking about dying in old
age you're definitely not going to trend
on twitter what part what would my face
on my gravestone be because the last
thing i want people talking about is
what i looked like when i died it's like
oh man that's what he looked like in his
old age i remember him from
30 years earlier
you know i don't want that to be the
conversation oh wow he really got old
well he kind of figures that he died you
know he was on how how old did you get
he really changed if you're talking like
kirk douglas old
i mean that man was old looking
you know
yeah but and and so his picture on his
gravestone is like spartacus but if
michael douglas
were to pass away and you saw current
michael douglas should be like
that's an old that's an old man but
ah he's a good looking guy i mean if it
were him i think i would want
catherine zeta jones on my gravestone
too just to
just to make it more interesting
like and then and like
a clarification that she's not buried
there we were just we were just married
so
look at her on this gravestone it's a
lot better than looking at old michael
douglas which isn't bad in and of itself
i'm not getting a picture is what i'm
saying but if i do i think it's going to
be of
um
i think it's going to be my
my velma haircut
you're going back to haircut like circa
2010 yeah
you remember our peak
well that is a conversation i want to
have and one of the things about getting
older i think
just where i land on this conversation
is
i haven't really thought about the
gravestone until i saw them out there
i don't necessarily think i'll get a
picture because where i'm gonna be
buried is probably not hollywood forever
cemetery i don't know where i'm gonna be
buried well i'm gonna be cremated i
don't know what i'm gonna do but if i do
get a picture it's gonna be an etching
and i think you can get away with an
ambiguous age
in the etching just make me look like it
could be the me that died
but not as old like take out the bags
under the eyes
which you i think you can get away with
with just an a sort of a line drawing an
example would be helpful
david letterman is a good example
he was famous for years for this one
thing he did then he went away and then
he came back and he had this huge beard
and like he looked older and different
but he looked distinguished and he was
like doing interviews on netflix
and i think that part of his career is
still kind of happening
he's certainly not dead but
if you told me if a couple of months
from now he passes away what what
version of him is going to be on his
headstone because i think both are
viable i think i mean the height of his
career was like i think it comes to the
late show height there are three
different options
late 80s there's three options for him
there's
nbc letterman
cbs letterman and current letterman
and i think the current letterman
doesn't stand a chance at night being on
the gravestone i think it comes down to
it
i wouldn't be appalled you know he was
still working he was still active he was
still a public figure so it's not like i
would be like
that's strange
i do know that he looked that way and he
may continue to i mean first of all is
he still got the huge beard and maybe 10
years from now he might not have a huge
beard he's going to really roll with
that for the rest of his life but but
his legacy
is his main show so i think from a
legacy standpoint if you can make a tie
to that then that's what you got to put
up i think it's early cbs so it's not
just completely unkempt curly hair it's
sort of a tight curl but it's not late
era cbs where you basically had a buzz
cut yeah he needs the curls to be
letterman it might be yeah yeah there we
go we figured it out for him a little
bit of weather now for ourselves
we could i think if i had okay if i okay
if i had to pick yours why don't you
pick you know what let's do that let's
do that right after the break we're
going to pick the what we think is the
physical the physical peak
not the physical peak what with the
physical
representation of the other guy because
we may have to make these decisions for
each other
but first we want to remind you about
the last chance section at mythical.com
we're always releasing stuff and then we
replace it with other stuff and we don't
just accumulate all the things we move
on that's why it's fun to like see when
something new comes out and decide if
you want it and then if you're on the
fence it's like you know it's it ain't
going to be there forever last chance
section is your place to know
that it's going away
so once it's gone it's gone forever
hence your last chance to get it
those uh the last chance section is
offered at a little bit
certain products are offered at a little
bit of a discount
um so go over there mythical.com
mythical.com rep your boys
okay i'm going to pick
uh
what i think you should have on your
gravestone and i'm not picking uh
velma
the velma haircut
i definitely think that your current
haircut is an improvement but i think i
would go with
uh when you back when you were dyeing
your hair
so this is a color i mean look i mean
i'm just saying i like the gray i think
you made the right decision i think
letting it go is the right thing but i
think that there's just this there was
look there was this little window of
time
in which you had the shape of the hair
that was a was better than the previous
version but it was still you look so
youthful you're so useful because you
you because you were dying it was so
unrealistically dark yeah bothers you
but i think that won't show up as much
in an etching on an etching
okay you know and it's also easier to
capture the gray in an etching i don't
even know how they'll do that
so i'm really just thinking about the
artist or the carver i mean deciding
about
if you if your etching has like long
hair or not really
is is an indication of what i believe
about the future our professional future
like are we going to accomplish enough
that
the most like it will be associated with
our legacy to apply that letterman
thing to us so i hope that's the case
you you got to do something man
to with that hairstyle
to earn the right to look like that on
your gravestone because right now i'm
telling you you got to go back to the
you got to go back to this shorter hair
for your gravestone oh man really yeah
i'm you just you you know i know i'm
really pushing the achiever button now
and i'm manipulating you
and uh i definitely plan on being along
for the ride well the interesting thing
is that that was
what you're getting at not related to my
hair but related to
achievement is is something i wanted to
talk about but let's talk about it um
you know i was actually in middle age
this is i mean
right that's what's getting you thinking
about this
the middle age of it all yeah
my wife
sent me
my wife will send me a tweet uh you know
my wife is a twitter fiend
you know
and uh she's always on there's a d on
the end of that and uh word
fiend a fiend is
i thought a fiend is like
uh
i thought a fiend was like an enemy but
a fiend is someone who's really into
something like addicted to something you
lose the d i don't i honestly don't i
don't know i i want to learn though all
right we'll find out but she's what did
she send you well what she'll do
is uh she will send me a tweet you're so
old that no she sent me a twitter thread
from a from a writer
who was talking about the creator of the
sopranos okay i don't remember his name
uh and anyway he was like i once went to
a
seminar or something with this guy
and basically
he was super bitter
about the fact that he had never made it
in film
he got basically forced to make the
sopranos into a television show it's a
long story but like that was the only
outlet it may have been like a
contractual thing with something that
it's not what he wanted even though it
became it redefined a television
institution no it didn't just become a
television institution but the way that
we think about television now and with
the golden age of television that we're
in and the fact that many actors would
prefer to be in a successful series
rather than a feature yeah is based on
the first person who really really did
that the first show that did that was
the sopranos this cinematic experience
of bringing you into a story in a super
meaningful and engrossing way
that felt like a movie this dude
basically made that happen but yet he
was bitter
about having never
made it in features now incidentally he
did write
and direct i believe that latest there's
a there's like a ray liotta
gangster movie that just is just coming
out now that's still in the sopranos
yeah yeah so he got to do it and he
finally got to do it
but anyway she sent that to me and she
knew exactly why she was sending it to
me because i'm constantly
uh
i guess more so than i even realized
complaining to her
about how hard it is for us to get to do
some of the other things that i think
that we should be doing now i'll premise
this with saying that
i'm old enough and wise enough at this
point to know
that regardless of whatever level of
success on any particular project lies
in the future
it will make me no happier it's not
about it's not believing that oh i will
finally be satisfied i will finally be
happy i know that my base level of
happiness
because this is just science will always
return to basically what it is and i
know
that
the process of making something
writing something
is probably maybe the best part of the
whole thing even if it never gets made
right
these things i know those facts
it does not stop me from feeling this
having this insatiable hunger
to achieve something else
but the thing that i've been thinking
about lately as it relates to my age
is like you know
at this point
regardless of what we
accomplish next
it is
very unlikely
that whatever we do even if it's
some big even if it's like a i mean a
movie is a movie and movies don't mean
as much as they used to right i
understand that but let's just say it
was a movie that like everybody was
talking about for a couple of weeks
which is like
the best that you can hope for or it's a
television show
that
everybody's talking about for a few
years because it gets a few seasons or
whatever these are like best case
scenarios
the cultural impact
of those
projects
will probably never be able to
surpass the cultural impact of good
mythical morning simply because yeah
we've done it for so long
it's 10 years it's 2 000 plus episodes
it's
millions and millions billions billions
of views
on this thing right that at the end of
the day and that represents lives touch
yeah and here's the thing i'm
i am super proud of what that show has
accomplished and what we've been able to
do through the show and i'm and and i am
passionate about the fact that it
impacts people and but at the same time
it it for the reasons we talked about
before on the show
it's me and you just kind of hanging out
and having fun it's not us creating
something and so the artist in me and
the creator in me still wants to have
that thing that i can point people to
and so and we've created an environment
here
with the mythical team where
it's
just as much a creative expression of
our team
in their specific roles as it is of us
expressing
our our friendship and our
points of view
whenever we do whatever they've set up
for us and it doesn't feel this but it's
not a creative challenge
day-to-day it's like a creative
collaboration between the two of us and
the way that some of the stuff that
we're working on now is like yeah if for
instance the
the movie
that we are writing and hoping to one
day make
it so representative of us and what
we're talking about to do yeah you're
talking about the s m movie yeah well
that is one way to describe it
but it's misleading because it's not
about sadomasochism yeah but that's what
that's what we're going to call it
because i want
when it is successful and when it is the
reason your gravestone face changes
rhett i want people to know that's what
specifically we were talking about our s
m movie yep
that's the that's all right so now we
have a code name the snm movie which by
the way just to give a timeline
we birthed that concept
not
less than a year ago like it might have
been early early 2021 yeah early 2010 no
2020
late 2020 because i remember it's
awesome
almost a year ago now i had this pie in
the sky idea that it would be written
like over christmas break
and it's right it's since then and
literally
the writing process starts
today yeah which is why it's so much on
the forefront of our mind because
there's been lots of outlining and all
that but when you think about legacy at
this age you really start to think about
legacy and there's other ways that you
think about it besides this but we might
as well get like fully explore
just the creative professional aspect of
our legacy because that is what we that
is what you start to think about at this
age well to me it's yeah it that's part
of it but i think the the the where the
age gets gets in there
is
a fear
that
my best work is behind me
like so it's kind of a two-part thing
that like okay can you are you even
capable of this
like
you know yeah okay sure you
this movie is there's going to be a
script
and that may be all that it ever is
um and we may get lucky enough for it to
be made for somebody to give us money to
make it
and then it's like well well people care
about it and like i said i know that the
happiness is not even if it people love
it it's not gonna make me any happier it
might make me happy for a day but i'll
immediately begin thinking about the
next thing that's just human nature
so it's not about that but it's about
kind of proving
to myself that i can that i can do this
there's this creative challenge that i
can't say no to
moving through it and being like hey
there it is i did that what's the next
thing that's just kind of how i live my
life but as i'm
now 44
there's this
man like
in reality we kind of got started at
this whole creative game kind of late
right like
you know when most youtubers were
getting started at 20 we were getting
started at 30. so we got a little bit of
like we got like a 10-year
uh we were delayed 10 years just because
of the nature of life we got into the
youtube game very early but like we've
been doing it for a very long time
but boy there's this part of me that's
like oh man i wish i could press a
button and be 34 because then i would
have this confidence that like how many
how many artists have really created
amazing things in their 40s and beyond
right like these are the things that i
start thinking i'm just being vulnerable
and honest about my fears it's just like
man if you haven't done it yet you
probably can't do it you're probably not
capable of it
and so then it's like and and listen
these are
very privileged problems i understand
that
many people in the entertainment
business would give
a limb to have the success that we have
had with good mythical morning alone i
get that that's not that's not what i'm
saying i'm not saying i'm not grateful
for this success we have had yeah but
there is this just like man is that
really is that gonna be it is that gonna
be the thing
that everyone remembers us for
and is that gonna be sort of the last
thing that we got to do that was
special to some to anyone just besides
the two of us yeah and i think
the way that i interact with this
because i also think about it is i i
find that my instinctive thoughts go
more towards
still this scarcity mentality and it
kind of being tied to
um
well is the money gonna run out before
my life does you know it's i just think
things like that it's like
uh
i
we have a we have a lifestyle that we
enjoy
say okay i wanna
i don't i don't want to have to go back
to being like doing things out of
obligation like we've been very
spoiled and privileged with like going
after our dreams and being successful
it
you know
on top of it so
i think we balance each other out well
that like you're you know i'm
i i tend to be grateful for what we have
and like oh i want to i want to maintain
this at all cost and you're great for
what we have but you want to build on it
as much as you can
and
so i you know i try to understand my
tendency and then put it in its place
and say hey i still do have ambition i'm
not just somebody who just
wants to maintain a lifestyle like
uh i don't want to be that person but we
i think we have different
different instinctive
like
drives at the heart of us
with me it's more of like maintain yeah
and my desire to to work on other things
is not really tied to any
um it's definitely not tied to finances
because i already know that the most
lucrative thing that i'll ever do is
good mythical morning i mean
very likely statistically speaking yeah
right because it's just so much content
and it's just it works really well for
us
if we we would have to have just like
this total moon shot of a moment
in
in tv or film or whatever
you know and again to begin to approach
that
i also i want to
because a lot of people whenever we talk
like this a lot of people are like what
guys why do you you have this obsession
with traditional media and it's only
because of your age and because you guys
grew up with tv and film yeah which to
the sopranos point yeah and like why
would you you you blaze the trail for
every other scripted show
and you still set the standard people
are rediscovering your work every day
and appreciating it
somehow because of tick-tock they're
watching sopranos and i think and i
think that
my particular hang up
is more i'm i'm saying this i i think my
particular hang up is more justified
than the sopranos guys uh hang up and
here's why
because he got to create a world like
the difference between the sopranos and
a film again it's just right it's format
the difference between
when i say tv and film i don't mean i'm
not i don't care about traditional media
like if you told me tomorrow that me and
you can make a movie with an adequate
budget in order to pull it off in the
way that we wanted to and it would just
go straight to youtube i'd be i that's
fine i it's not i'm not trying to win an
oscar i'm not trying to get
respect from any particular part of the
entertainment industry
i just want to be able to tell the kinds
of stories that we want to tell
and
right now there's just not a financial
model to do that
in the sort of completely owned and
controlled independent vehicle that we
have right now with digital media so it
kind of goes through the powers that be
and the finances and all that stuff so
it has nothing to do with an obsession
with
tv and film and traditional it's more
an obsession with storytelling now
until un until you check that box
and then you see what it becomes next
for you because it is a it is a moving
target well but it's something up but
it's some but it's it's the first thing
it's the first i i don't agree with that
because yeah my my interests are a
moving target
but we got into this business because we
wanted to tell stories we wrote
gutless wonders at 14 because we wanted
to tell stories we did a blood oath
because we wanted to tell stories like
when we said we wanted to create
something together
we we didn't know what it was
specifically but both of us were talking
about like we were talking about going
to film school like we we were talking
about creating a world telling stories
and we've been and we have been able to
do that in some fashion right and we got
to write a novel that was a world that
came to life and maybe that will become
something it isn't that we're not trying
we're still trying
um
but yeah to me it's the difference
between what we do on good mythical
morning which is it has an incredible
value and is incredibly rewarding
it's just the creative process for me
personally is a totally different thing
than something that we have
uh conceptualized or written and kind of
executed in birth in that way i get that
and i think if we if we shift to
um
like from a personal and
philosophical standpoint what it means
to be
to process being
middle-aged i think we could
we could superimpose that discussion
over top of what we've already discussed
because the the next thing that comes to
my mind that i'm grateful for about my
age is just starting to realize
perspective
starting to realize that i
actually do have some accumulated wisdom
uh
and
for me the the first place my brain goes
that i'm grateful for is
i feel like i'm well positioned to
know myself
like i was telling christy you know at a
younger age i'd i feel like i might have
had the desire and some of the drive to
to know myself understand what makes me
tick and
what ticks me off and every other type
of tick but there's something about
this age that i can i can start to
really experience
a level of self-knowledge that i just
don't think was possible
uh you know when we were in college or
when we were grinding and trying to make
it early on
you know
so i'm i'm actually enjoying that that
again we have the luxury of having some
space and time
to
give attention to ourselves
in a way that's like i'm i'm still
evolving
i'm still changing and i'm very
committed to
being in touch with that process and
understanding myself and i think that
that is a portion of that with us is
aging
i think
also a big portion of it is the
worldview change that we that we had
right so i think yeah it was like we
were being redefined
in our but specifically late 30s
what i'm getting at is
when you are an evangelical christian or
when i was an evangelical christian
there is a
thinking a little bit too like too much
focus on self
you know like
it's all about attention to god right
and you are small and god is big and
there are some very good things about
the mentality of like not centering
yourself and humbling yourself and i
believe that there are some good
qualities there but one of the things
that kind of gets wrapped up in that is
that any sort of self-discovery and
looking into yourself and knowing that
there's something in there that needs to
be expressed and to come out can begin
to you start confusing that with sinful
pride
and so in my the way my personality
processed a lot of that structure was
this feeling that like i'm not important
enough to really figure myself out no
i'm not saying that's everybody but i
think it stunted my growth of sort of
self-realization and self-discovery
when i got out of that way of thinking
about things
and started thinking like i gotta really
figure myself out it's not just about
understanding
god and the bible and then my
my relationship to that but it's also
like this is the body and mind that i
have i need to kind of figure out
who i am and there's nothing wrong with
that and that sort of
you can call it selfishness
but
directing some actual attention to
yourself
learning how to love yourself so that
you then can actually be a better
citizen and a better you know you know
love people better and be less selfish
and self-absorbed
for me
i think that was the beginning of a
process that eventually led to therapy
and led to the sort of self-discovery
and figuring out who i am and as a
enneagram three another
thing that happens is that you're really
good at figuring out who everyone else
wants you to be
you can
analyze a person or a group of people
figure out the
um
the ideal
and then you just adopt that ideal
and it wasn't until like the past five
years or so that i began to figure out
so many of the things that
i
liked or a lot of the ways that i
presented myself
were just based on
people's perception
and so for me getting older a part of it
has been a discovering myself
but b also being able to embrace some
things about myself
irrespective of people's perspective of
me is there an example that comes to
mind
of like something that you realize you
were doing because of that um because i
don't know exactly what you're talking
about
as it relates to you
well it it's more of a it's more of a
disposition
of thinking about like
oh
is that something that i
want or is that something that i think
that someone thinks i should want
uh and it could i mean it could be
something as simple as oh i i'm going to
like this
movie or whatever i'm going to say that
i like this movie because i think that
other people like this movie
and i started realizing that it was just
kind of built into my dna
to be able to kind of anticipate
what the sort of the collective
consciousness about something was going
to be and tapping into that and it's and
this is still a struggle for me to be
like
what do you actually think
about
this right i mean a good example is what
we talked about
a couple weeks ago with the guitar right
getting a tailor getting a taylor guitar
because it was what i thought that i
should like at the time in the
environment that i was in and then
slowly as i as i got older being like i
feel i find myself liking these other
sounds
and what and then i go and i look up
well what does so-and-so play what does
so-and-so play like oh that's not that's
not a taylor that's a that's a martin or
okay that's a gibson and it's like
that's the sound that you actually liked
but when i go when i went to the music
store even the last time i bought a
guitar when i went into the music store
it's like i only i i sat down and i just
played the tailors right and it was it's
just this weird thing and it's not
because i think that oh liking taylor is
better it's just you made that decision
in the past for somebody else and now
you kind of just carried it through into
adulthood
so it's kind of this peeling back things
like that yeah i
the peeling back experience to get to
the core of myself is something that i'm
i i'm now in a position to do
for me
evangelicalism growing up in that was
like okay
i want to aggressively learn the system
so that then i can
know enough about it and put into
practice
you know the spiritual disciplines and
then i can go about the rest of my life
like
having fully explored the manual and
just executing it yeah it's not about
asking
difficult questions or like wringing my
soul out to to really analyze
who i am and and the whys of life for me
it's in because that felt like a a scary
burden
apart from just someone giving me all
the answers in a nice package yeah it
turns out the package wasn't completely
nice
but i gained a lot of security from that
and i did have this mentality that was
i'm going to
just the the second half of my life is
just going to be about
applying everything that i've already
learned
i just didn't anticipate that there
could be so much more to learn out there
and
there was a lot of fear in kind of
crossing over to the other side because
of all the unknowns that we've
discussed
but yeah actually being there is a very
freeing and rewarding and still at times
very scary process because
it's um
it's not
well laid out and rigid
it's much more fluid
but
it enabled it it's enabled me to know
myself at a at a totally deeper level
and i think that's the
that's the that's the experience that i
want to define my life
i find myself talking a lot in therapy
about situations that i'm going through
and experiencing and then discussing
making meaning of it
you know how as humans we want to we
want to make meaning that that that
enriches an experience and kind of
codifies it
in our in our memories
as not in being being present
and making the most of of something like
just wringing everything out of it that
there is you know i think is
is the philosophy and the approach that
that i'm taking now and it's something
that
it i think it's still a struggle for me
it's something i've i've identified this
is how i want to live my life
but i also know enough about myself that
uh i'm prone to be stuck in my ways you
talk about the second
the second half of life and just
the whole trope of being set in my ways
is something that is a discussion that
goes on a lot at my house whether it's
you know just
deciding that i want things to be in a
certain way and routines are so huge for
me especially as an enneagram one it's
like once i've figured something out
i'm gonna make the smoothie this way and
not only that but i'm gonna make it at
this time and i'm gonna get my
ingredients in this way and if anybody
messes anything up
that really irks me
or i have these plans to do something
with the kids like yesterday we're going
to go one wheeling and i'm like texting
you so i can borrow one for you from
lincoln i'm like and make sure that
things charged up and then i go out to
get them
uh
mine and put them in the trunk before i
go pick up you're fully charged when i
realized
lando's has been in the back of my car
for two weeks and it's it barely has any
charge and i was so upset
and that that's one of the first things
when i was like bouncing this this
discussion off of christy she was like
you know
getting older you get
you have a tendency to be set in your
ways and anything that throws that off
just it really
it really throws you off
and
if you don't
and i agree with this so it wasn't like
a warning out of the blue but it was
like hey if you don't look out for this
you're going to become somebody who just
builds this these walls around yourself
and says i'm just trying to maintain
what i have
and the way that i want it and then it
lets
fewer and fewer new experiences in so i
think that's the
that's the tension that i'm experiencing
at this point in
mid-life is
knowing enough of who i am
to celebrate and love myself but not
allow that to keep me from
who i'm still going to become yeah so
even having the words to say that
is
is a
is a part of the journey that i've been
on just in the last few years and that i
really enjoy
in saying
you know the openness from leaving
evangelicalism and saying like i want to
be open-minded and open-hearted
and then applying that to things beyond
just your spiritual beliefs but to every
aspect of your life is something that
um
i'm still growing into well one of the
things that
maybe an unspoken well it's actually not
unspoken because
evangelical christians
uh and christians in general see god one
of the characteristics of god the
attributes of god is his immun
immutability right which means he does
not change that's one of the things that
makes god god he is always the same and
so that becomes something that you kind
of aspire to
implicitly
uh and i think there's also an obsession
in our because when you're right why
change there's also an obsession in our
culture with
um
staying the same right we get so mad
when a when a politician flip-flops on
something and it's like that's the
stupidest perspective i've ever heard in
my life because you know what new
information
causes people to change their mind now
it's one thing if somebody flip-flops
and many politicians flip-flop because
of convenience and wanting to app to be
you know more electable that's one thing
right but when somebody's like i used to
think this about this issue now i think
this because my view has evolved that's
something that should be that process
should be celebrated that's not some
reason to like somebody but i think one
of the things that because we have
experienced this incredible evolution
and this upheaval of our worldview
it's given us this this
just sort of underlying belief that it's
not about
being
this certain way and figuring that out
and just staying that way it's just like
there's a version of rhett 10 years from
now and then a version of 20 years from
now and i hope that those versions are
better but i know that those versions
are going to be different and they may
be different in ways that i can't
anticipate and that's a super exciting
thing now there are some things that may
be more of a refining process of kind of
figuring yourself out you know when you
talk about the uh
the sort of like savoring and being in
the moment one of the things that i've
kind of embraced about myself
is that i have a really difficult time
doing that right
um we even wrote our whole
chapter in the book of mythicality about
stopping and celebrating and i'm not
saying that i don't agree with that in
general like if you achieve something
you know stop and enjoy it
and really appreciate this moment but
there's also just a there's a the way
that i am and the way that i sort of
operate in the world is that the moment
that i achieve one goal
i'm ready for the next thing and i think
that
i'm starting to understand that that's
not a bad thing for me you know what i'm
saying like
that whole process like every single
stage along the part along the different
steps of a project and then it finally
coming to fruition like when i get kind
of focused on that moment of achieving
and that moment of completing and being
like hold on everybody let's stop and
really celebrate and let's go to dinner
and let's really milk this for all it's
worth
for me it's kind of like
i want to milk each step for all it's
worth and make sure that i'm not just
looking at that
accomplishing the goal as being the
end-all because
really it may be like i said the writing
the conceptualizing that ends up when i
look back on this the most fun part of
this whole process wasn't when we
finally screened that movie it was when
we came up with the idea or when we had
that breakthrough in the storytelling
process
and then the thing is is that it's not
going to make me any happier anyway so
why don't you just move on to the next
thing like i'm learning to like not
get upset with myself
for
i don't want to say not being present
because i want to be present i want to
be present at each step
but not stopping and saying that like
i'm going to make a huge freaking deal
out of this thing it'd be it's like what
is that does that come natural to me
it's like
not really i mean i'm going to enjoy it
and let's let's celebrate but hey i know
that the next day i'm going to wake up
and i'm going to be like what's next and
that's oh and that's okay and that may
be something that's good about me right
versus being like oh you can never be
satisfied and that's bad maybe that sort
of
insatiable hunger for the next thing
is just part of my disposition and my
personality and something i should just
embrace
the moment that i begin thinking that i
can find my happiness and the things
that i achieve i've gone off track but
if i can find happiness in
the process
and knowing that hey man it's one of the
things i've been talking about with my
therapist is that
as i talk about
the different facets of what we do
professionally
and of course being
essentially ceos of a media company
takes up a fair amount of time
uh and of course that's not my favorite
part of what we do my favorite part of
what we do is the creative part
and the way he kind of the way my
therapist kind of described it he was
like you kind of get into the way you
talk about it is as if you're in sort of
a zone when you're in this creative zone
and as you get older you're learning to
make sure that you're getting that time
and you're getting that creative space
because that's where you find life
any and
he's helped me be able to see that
it's that's not an unhealthy thing
because when i start describing it to
him i start describing it in this like
i feel a little bit guilty for how bad i
want to do x y and z like that's my
threeness that's my
achiever and that's my performer and
that and that's bad because i'm trying
to find my identity in the things that
i'm creating and he's like
no no no
there is a incredible
and health and life
in your
being in a creative zone and finding
life in that creative process that's a
good thing now the moment that you start
trying to do it for other people and
you're starting to do it for adulation
and and people to kind of pat you on the
back that's that's trouble but
understanding that you need that and you
want that and you're never gonna like
you're never gonna be satisfied unless
you're creating and that might be the
next thing
that's a good thing so that's that's
something that i've so i've sort of let
go of my guilt of being like what we
talked about earlier like the fact that
yeah we do we're doing all this other
stuff but i still have
10 other things that i want us to do
that's not a bad thing and i can embrace
that and that's not unhealthy
you know what i'm saying yeah definitely
and i think that it's
again it's back to understanding enough
about
myself you understand enough about
yourself to
to to begin to parse
what your motivations are and but not to
beat yourself up
and not to
not to over interpret things it's like
every single thing
that you pour yourself into
there's
it could lead to a problem or it could
lead to
something worth celebrating it's there's
it's gray right
but if you're yeah i'm glad to hear that
you're like not beating yourself up and
just reducing
your desire to something that
is is like
motivated by the wrong things but
gaining clarity i think it's
again at our age we have we can't have
enough perspective to gain clarity
on
what a vibrant life can look and feel
like for each of us and understanding
the parts of it that are actually
healthy like that was a big shift for me
um
[Music]
you know i'm thinking about it because
this movie that we're right in the
middle of this creative process if you
told me like i should be okay
if for some reason i was able to look
into the future and find that this movie
was never going to be made into anything
other than a script
now that would be disheartening for sure
i like to believe that it's going to
happen but
the process of writing it
should be
enjoyable and vibrant and life-giving
regardless of the outcome if it doesn't
get made into a movie it doesn't
mean that the process of writing it and
developing it was for nothing
because there was joy and life in the
process yeah
and that's a huge shift for me as a as
an achiever like i can't let i can't get
rid of the engine
that is always putting me it's always in
a certain gear and as soon as the moment
you turn it off and say hey let's let
the engine rest then i'm just like ah
let's
turn the engine back on i can't stop
that about myself and that's not
necessarily unhealthy it's the
perspective if all of a sudden that
engine is running for everybody else's
expectations
and so that that's been a huge shift
that's kind of happened in the in the
therapy process with me i'm kind of just
hey this is who you are this is how
you're this this is how you're built
embrace it and know the pitfalls yeah i
mean there's so many ways that we're
alike so many ways we're different but
when you talk about letting go of other
people's expectations for me i'm like
yeah i think my my
practice is letting go of my own
expectations that i've created and and
this you know to have this sense of
and practice of control
like this morning i you know i've got my
mountain bike right the ride that i do
and if it's the same so i can measure
myself against it in order to get better
to be a little faster
and uh more more efficient
which shows progress
but i heard a al hooting
and i made a decision you know what i'm
going to find this owl and this morning
you know you've been talking about owls
for a couple of months now and how
you've seen them it's kind of i've been
seeing that
and then i looked up
and i saw an owl it was it was very dark
the sun hadn't come up yet so it was
like the silhouette of an owl on this
big power tower you know the power
towers the power towers
uh yeah so i i saw an owl it's a
beautiful thing and i stopped my route
i paused my podcast did you call to him
and i listened and looked at the owl and
then i rode around the other side and uh
i wanted to see the back side of the owl
but then his head can turn around all
the way yeah give or take yeah which is
an owl thing which is cool to experience
did he do that i think he did that he
looked at you he was his his head turned
around yeah i mean it was a silhouette
but i that's what i was imagining you
choose to believe that he was pivoting
to look at you yeah
let's talk about things we hate about
getting old well this this for me this
can be quicker i think what you got at
with the mountain biking it ties into
something that i was thinking which is a
little bit of good and a little bit of
bad with getting old so there is this
refining process from a physical
standpoint right so you're talking about
the mountain biking and
uh improving your times and
but the problem is is that your body is
only heading in the wrong direction so
you can you can get and i've been
thinking about this because you know i'm
i'm pretty physically active
and i work out on a pretty regular basis
and a lot of it is based on
sort of like thinking about my
at the things i want to be able to do in
longevity especially as it relates to my
back right so
my back has been a problem on and off
even when i was looking at those
anniversary videos or the honeymoon
videos that we ended up putting into the
podcast with jesse and christy on it
i listened to some of them with the
sound on and one of the things i was
complaining about in that video when i
was 23 was how bad my back was hurting
so this is a long this is a multi huh
most you know over a couple of decades
of struggling with this
and so
so much of my like working out is
designed to make my back better and a
few months ago i was getting to a place
where i was like doing squats and dead
lifts and i was like i think i've
overcome my back issues i always get to
this place and then i like pushed it a
little too hard and i had my uh broke it
broke i had a
moment and that actually set me on a
course of
what it was a couple of months of of
dealing with the pain and not being able
to work out in the way that i wanted to
but i ended up kind of embracing when i
came out of that time i was like you
can't like you don't need to be you
don't need to be doing deadlifts okay i
mean
even just just let's just take deadlifts
out of the of the uh the workout routine
it just doesn't make any sense right i
mean it's got the word dead in it but th
this was
there's this idea that
there's a sort of physical refinement
like i'm learning the things that hurt
my back
i'm learning the things that hurt my
i've got a shoulder thing right i got a
shoulder thing and i'm learning oh i had
to change my goal even though i don't
play golf that often i like i i have
like a net that i hit balls into at my
house just kind of like on a pretty
regular basis i'll go out there and hit
10 balls or something i've had to change
my swing based on a new pain in my back
but also my shoulder
and so
there's this this idea that
you're refining and you're learning some
things about your body
but at the same time every single
process in your body is heading in the
wrong direction and every single thing
that you're dealing with is only going
to
all the factors are stacked against you
you can resist it and you can do a
really good job of trying to like stay
in shape et cetera
but everything is just heading in the
wrong direction that's that's a
there's a sense of impending doom when
you really think about that well yeah i
think in the way that we discuss
parenting as being like okay you shift
to this paradigm of harm reduction
like definitely
understanding my body is another way
i've gotten in touch more with
my body
like
knowing what the limits are
and
for my physical therapist gaining an
education on
like okay when you reach too far like
you hyper extend yourself and then
that's a danger zone so actually knowing
the
the safe limits with which i can reach
and reach for what
anything uh any jar yeah like um you
know like i'm sure with your with your
back and like when i worked at ibm and
like in the warehouse they would have
all these things about how to properly
lift something yeah and lift with your
legs not your back two-man lift don't
twist don't lift and twist
all these things that you know at our
age you really start to understand
okay my sh the way that my shoulders are
built and my collarbones and
my rotator cuffs like i can really
i have to be aware because my body will
go if if i push it to the limit like
physically
that will cause damage i have to have to
be aware of that and educate myself yeah
and know that i'm just trying to re do
things to be active and to strengthen
myself but reduce harm
you know not hurt myself every time i go
to the gym it's like this could be the
day that i hurt myself and i'm not gonna
be able to go back to the gym yeah like
mountain biking i see like
guys who are
10
15 years older than me out there
doing exactly what i'm doing that gives
me hope it's like okay there's
there's a version of mountain biking
that i can continue into older age
because i'm probably i'm not gonna get
into golf
you know like you are there's a version
of golf that you can do as long as you
don't have like
as long as you continue to know your
limits right yeah
and it's it's tough but there are some
things like
i'm def i definitely relate to the like
the way that i hold myself i mean i'm
sure you can just look at some of the
more physical videos that we do like
i'm a little stiff i i'm actually like
if you go back to like
old rat like young red like i was like i
was i'm not i'm not floppy i'm not stiff
i was like super flexible and i'm
actually still flexible but i don't
move the center of my body
and really
i'm careful with how i move because i'm
so concerned with getting hurt
and then like walk like i remember you
know if i'm like hiking and i'm
going really quickly down a mountain i
remember the way that i used to do that
as a kid and sometimes it would just
start running remember that time we like
ran down grandfather mountain yeah and
it's like now i'm going like
30 percent speed if i'm if i'm running
but like
my whole core is like really tight
because i'm like the core has got to be
tight like there's just a whole lot of
extra
going on but then there's things like oh
i know that this food will
uh cause my psoriasis to flare up or i
know if i have a if i drink alcohol two
days in a row oh you're gonna get a
flare up
uh if you eat this food
you really should take a beano before
you eat this food or you might you know
what if you have this particular meal
you should just go ahead and take a dose
of pepto-bismol right after you get
through with it there's these old-man
ways of thinking about things that are a
little bit disheartening but it's also
you figure some stuff out you you're not
just you can't because you're because
you're not young anymore you can't just
go into a situation where reckless
abandon and be like i'll deal with the
consequences but you're also learning
some things about yourself physically so
that you can prepare for them so there's
good there's there's two sides of that
there's some good in it and then but the
ultimate reality is it's all heading in
the wrong direction when you talk about
the 10 to 15 years i mean are you
talking you've got 10 to 15 years left
to mountain biking and then you're gonna
hang it up you can't think of it like
that obviously yeah but that is sort of
the overhanging reality is that it's all
gonna get harder
and more difficult and more
consequential as we get older and you
just have to
accept it i'll tell you the other thing
i hate is
hair popping up in places like
i realize i've got all this hair growing
on my ears now
like i'm not covered up with other i
mean not inside of the ear like the
outside edge like right here yeah
i've got hairs growing and that there's
black ones
you gotta have somebody in your life who
sees that i shaved this morning and
helps you with it and every time that i
shave
i have this i have a magnifying mirror
like first of all here's something that
i learned that i don't
like a commitment to actually look at
myself in the mirror
like okay this is you i'm gonna look at
it and i'm gonna assess it and i'm gonna
do i'm gonna make decisions to do stuff
about it and i'm gonna make decisions
about what i'm not gonna do stuff about
and i'm just gonna i'm gonna accept who
i am and figure out what i'm gonna what
i'm gonna work on here christy's giving
me all these lotion like night lotions
it's like what's happening i have
glasses i don't know if you knew that
but if i take those off like
the thing that the glasses covers up is
the place where there's like that's
where age happens yeah so glass i've
i've been able to do a nice thick glass
in the open for many years yeah and i've
been hiding behind these glasses like
the red out chili peppers i don't know
how old they are now i think they might
be pushing
they're in their mid-50s at least yeah
they announced their new tour and it was
like trending on youtube and i was like
damn
i mean they look old but but not as old
as they are yeah but i was like we're
still going to be announcing tours and
doing stuff one day and people are going
to be reacting we're going to have to
say things like jon stewart with his new
show
i don't know if you've seen the
promotions for his new show but he's
like yeah
this is what i look like now yeah he's
like totally gray and like wrinkle-faced
and just aged yeah and it's because he
went away for a little bit and he came
back and he's like this is whatever yeah
this is what i look like i've noticed
this uh now that we're we're on tick
tock and
there's people who were you know 10
years old or whatever or the last time
they watched us
and
wow wow
you guys got old now we did here's this
at the same time i'm i'm grateful for
the fact that i do think we're aging
rather gracefully there's things that we
do
most people are surprised to hear we're
as old as we are we've got full heads of
hair there's lots to be grateful for in
the physical department and i'm grateful
for the gray hair because i'm just
grateful for the hair right uh but at
the same time it it there are days in in
again like you said i don't i don't wear
glasses and also my i i have my eyes are
different than i have different kinds of
eyes that are a little bit buggier and
ha and i and i have sort of i don't know
what the genetic name for the what the
name for this is but i have the i have
the sort of eye bags i've had them
forever but like they're the kinds of
things i can i look at old men certain
old men and i'm like he's got my kind of
eyes and that's where i'm headed and the
aging apps like some fans have sent us
through those and like the like the
donald sutherland version of you yeah
that is so we both look so real because
i look like
my grandad
and when he was elderly
and like how my dad's getting now it's
like oh my god like that is scarily
accurate i know exactly but for some
reason i'm still wearing the exact same
glasses which i think may be the case i
think when i'm 80 i might still be
wearing these glasses because i've been
trying to change them up and i keep
going back to them
but the other i mean i got hair i shaved
the hair on my ears
just to keep it down and i'll use the
nose hair trimmers inside of my ears and
boy i've looked at the side of your ear
to know that you got a lot of that stuff
happening inside of your ear but i don't
think you have the outer rim black hair
growth that i do but i mean i got to get
down in that magnifying glass and look
at it so back to what i was saying about
looking at yourself in the mirror the
thing that i noticed
was that i just i just don't look at
myself enough i think there's a lot of
people who look at themselves too much
and they obsess about things and it's
it's not healthy but the thing that i
would notice is when i'm getting ready
in the morning and like fixing my hair
i will
over the course of fixing my hair i will
step back
and step back and i will realize that i
have gotten like four or five paces
from the mirror
while i'm fixing my hair the longer i
fix my hair the further from the mirror
i get and i do i it's just some i think
it's a subconscious practice of
i'm a i'll probably be happier with it
if i don't scrutinize it as much
and then i when i'm done i like i have
to take five steps back up to the mirror
and like certify am i am i good
because i actually it's kind of a good
practice like maybe you're getting
different angles to be far from somebody
it's like all right i spotted link
i recognized him and i had a conclusion
about what he looked like i got this
because i've done the five paces but
then i've gone back up and it's like now
i'm gonna go up and talk to him
and now i'm gonna see is that
like
is there is there a zit on his face if
you get really close is there hair on
his ears if he gets intimate like
there's sometimes when i really go
through a process and i'm like i'm gonna
use that magnifying mirror i'm gonna get
rid of all this stuff i have hairs
growing on my nose like black black
hairs yeah yeah growing on the bridge of
my nose i'll get those i don't shave
those you pluck those i pluck those
individually and and i've gotten pretty
good at it like if i
sometimes i'll just like touch the
bridge of my nose and i can feel if
there's a hair that needs to be plucked
do you use a serum a face serum uh
like an it's like an oil with a dropper
yeah that's got like the blood of
virgins in it not yet i'm sure i will
once you finish talking about it oh i
use it i mean at night it's a night
serum well it makes it nice and shiny
well it's actually
they suggest that you use it in the
morning what i found is my eyes are so
sensitive and already very red all the
time if i don't put my drops in um i
really can't put anything on my face
in the morning i just wash it and i put
a little little moisturizer here on some
spots like some i have like some like
eczema
or psoriasis or something that will kind
of pop up on my face but
i um
so i started doing it at night i've
actually been doing i don't know if you
if you knew this but i've been doing the
uh
i've been putting like moisturizer
moisturizer like anti-aging moisturizer
on my
face for like
i don't know like seven or eight years
well how would i know that you're
keeping this a secret you're trying to
you're trying to you're trying to
underage me i mean you got to give me
these serums christy's been giving me
these serums
i haven't maybe you haven't realized but
i've been doing um i've got some night
creams but the but yeah but now i'm
pretty much down to man this this one i
got this one
this stuff
it's a it's a little bottle
it'll last you a couple of months
it's a hundred and fifty dollars good
god but it's the only thing
that i that i'm currently using because
i was using like a
retinol thing and then like a
moisturizer over that but like i'm
pretty much just doing that because i
mean listen i am like i'm trying to i'm
trying to delay the inevitable um yeah i
don't necessarily i know that we're
gonna we're gonna eventually look our
age but i'm like why not try to why not
try to stave it off as long as possible
now the real question is gonna be when i
do get the donald sutherland bags
because they're coming and they're
coming with a vengeance
i'm not is there going to be like this
moment like 15 20 years from now when
i'm you know 65 years old
when all of a sudden i started thinking
whatever kenny rogers thought before he
got his bags removed and suddenly like a
different person yeah you don't want to
do that
you don't want to you don't want to you
don't want to assume an alter ego late
in life right but but what when you're
cosplaying as your younger self but it
looks like a mask but then you've got
some doctor who says like hey i can do
it i can do this and no one will no one
will know oh you're paying 150 for a
serum
i can do some stuff for you
i got some i'm not ruling oceanfront
property and i'm not ruling any arizona
right now i'm not ruling anything out
hey you you shouldn't the way
technology's changing donald you could
uh you'll be just fine
but that yeah it is
talk about eyes it's an eye-opening
experience to see that
those aged photos of us and you know you
start to think i want to be
healthy enough to toss my grandchildren
around
and a little bit of those
great-grandchildren and i want to be
able to see them through my eye bags
yeah i don't want them pulling on them
granddad
let me let me pull on your eye bags i
don't hate too much besides my my hair
i've i've pretty much given up on the
fact that like i'm never gonna have a
a big chest
like i can't get i'm never going to have
a baby i can't make my chest have muscle
on it like my pecs won't do anything and
when i try to build it all it does is
mess up my shoulders because i'm like we
need to get you on the marvel marvel i'm
doing like push-ups and now my shoulder
hurts
or a bench press i can't do any of that
stuff i can like that's the other thing
i haven't liked about my my body
is i just can't
i can't get pecs to grow well you're
doing pretty good in the shoulder
department the show that's the thing i
work on constantly i just you know i i
won't i i don't i don't like the shape
of everything so i can get a chest yeah
you can you can't get i don't i don't
even work my chest out anymore because
i'm like it's big enough okay it's like
let's work on the shoulders but
i think this is it i think this is
unless with our powers combined i think
unless i start uh if i get on gear as
lock would say
that's the head gear that's the term for
steroids seriously your son wants you to
take steroids no i'm saying like he's
like he's like dad all those guys all
those
guys superheroes
in the marvel movies they're on gear dad
that's not that's not natty
natural okay
uh he's not suggesting i'd do it he's
just like but if you really wanted to
get big you'd have to get on gear
anything else you hate so i just i just
wanted
if all of a sudden i'm really big i'm
probably on steroids what else do you
hate i just want to make sure we don't
miss anything about getting older yeah
you know we've i've thoroughly
established how much i do not like
myself without a beard people talked
about when they saw my uh honeymoon
videos in my wedding pictures of like
see red doesn't look bad without a beard
well
i was 23 years old one of the things
that i discovered
when i shaved for buddy system was that
one of the things that happens as you
get older is you gain weight right here
like the little bit of chin that i had
that i was able to kind of show when i
weighed like 185 pounds when i was 22
years old
um
that's been filled in
right it's been and even i don't know
i'm if i if i was like i'm gonna get
super thin and get super cut and then
i'm gonna shave and see what it looks
like i'm not gonna do that but like
that's another thing is that
the turkey chin that is an inevitable
part of getting old okay i'm not not
happy about that but i have a beard to
cover it up so when you get turkey chin
oh yeah you're to have to make a
decision
i'm going to grow a beard
i think i am yeah
i just
i've always been a fan of the lord of
the rings legolas and not the hobbit
legolas so i'd rather get a chicken chin
than whatever happened to his face like
he got like a chiseled face
like a i don't know what happened
i don't want to know
but babyface legolas is the one that
i'm gonna remain true to wow i've never
thought about this different his face
was just totally different and they did
some cgi stuff too because it was
supposed to be he's supposed to be
younger
yeah he's supposed to be younger but his
face was like he
i mean orlando bloom
his face bloomed you know what i'm
talking about it's weird uh he and it
wasn't elvish anymore last thing i'll
say
is
i definitely feel like i've kind of
transitioned into a place where
i need more things to be explained to me
i i actually i i saw uh matt carney
tweeted
recently something about like
appreciating the the younger gmm writers
who always put notes in their scripts
uh that say thank you for explaining
this young reference to me right
and even even though we've got kids and
so we are a little bit more in the know
but not for long they're going to be
gone soon
there is this
being
trying to be a part of internet culture
and and
you know we know that we're like sort of
youtube dads and we know that when we do
go on tik tok people see us as these dad
characters they don't see us as like
their peers which is totally fine and
normal and natural but i just find
myself hearing things
and needing someone to explain it to me
and feeling a little bit more out of the
loop about more
ideas concepts slaying etc and that's
only increasing that's i'm only going in
the wrong direction and then it's so
good for your brain to stay engaged like
the way that you're engaged in tick-tock
is
good for your brain it keeps you young
and yes it's a losing battle and at a
certain point we're just not gonna care
and whatever the next tick-tock is you
probably won't care and then my version
of that is
okay i am going to try to appreciate
what is magical about trippy red's music
you know i'm going to try
i can connect with lincoln that way
but i've made a decision from a music
standpoint
i should be able to
i should be able to appreciate what's
happening now yeah
so that that's the place where i've
decided to keep my mind young and not
allow myself to fart on something i
don't understand
but also to be engaged as much as i can
not for clout but just just
just for what it does for me are you
going to change the way you talk
that's another thing i think i cannot do
that i can't like i've never like i hear
the new slang and i'm like i just can't
do it i ca like even 100
i cannot say so many people now say 100
percent like when you're not even new
it's not even new slang it's like 75
sling 75 like somebody's saying no it's
not 100 like i agree with that 100 i say
that and i i've said that since i was no
20 no you haven't it is a it has now
become a social
colloquialism over the past five years
hundred
hundred that's different
one hundred percent just
conversationally when you agree with
somebody saying 100 percent
is something
i can't even do that okay well that's
i take issue with that because i don't
feel like i've adopted any slang and i
said that is slang it is slang but it's
one that you felt like you could adopt
because it's
it's not young people slaying
exclusively it's actually i think it's
more of um
it might be
our age slang but it's still something i
can't do i'm using it as an example of
something i should be able to but i just
can't well but i don't know because and
saying bro like that's like i can't say
i cannot call anybody bro
i can't do that well you bruh or that
definitely there like there's so many of
them
but i just feel like i'm at this point
i'm so
i'm so far behind
because at some point i i've never been
i've never wanted to
oh you seem like you're talking that way
because you're trying to connect with
somebody so i don't think i should
but
the more that you don't do it and the
older that you get it becomes that then
you all you you sound like an old person
and you don't even know it like right
now it's still like borderline i can
have a conversation with a teenager and
they'll just be like this he's a dad you
know he's not you but like
20 years from now if i'm talking exactly
the way that i am right now which is
most likely the case at that point
i'll be using words that
the way that you perceive like an old
person who says like
what what did like old people say when
when something is great um serendipitous
i don't know but so be like a
grandfather so be it and i see yeah i'm
accepting that right 100
um all right you got a wreck i do uh and
i do think it's relevant uh which mine
are usually not but this one is
there's a documentary it was recorded
recommended to uh me by a friend called
beauty is embarrassing it's not a new
documentary it's been out almost 10
years it's about
an artist named wayne white
who is the guy who
did all the like puppets and stuff for
pee-wee's playhouse like he was back in
in that
doing all that stuff he's a southern boy
that we would that we really relate to i
mean he's older than us but
um
a small town southern guy
who kind of got out of the south and
went to the big city and pursued this
career in the in you know entertainment
but the story is really about how he has
continued to stay creatively engaged and
had these like multiple
sort of career
phases where all of a sudden he just
invented a whole new thing that he was
doing that he became known for
and uh it's just it's super inspiring to
see somebody
so committed to
their own creative pursuit
in a way that's not related to trying to
be successful in a conventional sense
but just following their creative
instincts wherever they might lead
now for him the result has been that it
has been very
rewarding
and commercially successful
but he's just a delightful guy it's a
really awesome story wayne white is his
name again the documentary's beauty
beauty is embarrassing okay
hashtag ear biscuits we'll speak at you
next week let us know
what you think if you're middle aged or
hope to be one day
make us feel better about it
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]